what is a woman
[Music]
um
well can you tell me what a woman is no
I can't you know it's a combination of
your physical attributes and then what
you're showing to the world and the
gender clues that you give so it looks
like we've got a bunch of people on Tick
Tock giving their own attempts at
defining the word woman I've yet to hear
a good definition from anybody on the
left I'm always ears wide open for
anyone who wants to give it a try so
let's just start at the top with uh clip
one can we talk about the definition of
woman for a second please because I'm
really tired of people saying that oh
lips can't even Define the word woman
well first of all I'm not a liberal I'm
a leftist so let me tell you what the
definition of woman is
oh
there isn't one
not this again yes Francine this again
gender is a social construct and as such
the definition of woman which is a
gender will change depending on where
and who you are the definition for
gender overall will be different across
countries biologically speaking it
doesn't even make sense to try and
Define a woman through biology because
not all females are the same example
number one some can't have kids everyone
who says that motherhood is what makes
you a woman is literally just
invalidating every woman who either
can't have kids or doesn't want to have
kids the same applies to sexual organs
and genitalia okay
um
so let's start with there isn't a
definition for a woman well to begin
with then stop using the word you cannot
use a word if you if it doesn't have a
definition if by your own telling it has
no definition then what do you do in
using it so just as a comparison if I
tell you this hey I was walking down the
street the other day and I saw a I saw a
zipper do I saw a zipper dude when I was
walking on the street can you believe it
I saw it it was this really big zipper
dude and then you said what's that what
does a zipper do what do you think
that's what is it and I said oh it
doesn't have this not anything it
doesn't have a definition
you see the problem here how can I
possibly be talking about a thing that
has no meaning and no definition this is
this is Inc becomes incoherent Babel
please no gibberish tonight please I beg
you are you Daddy so
if that is what you actually believe
then you are not allowed to use the word
anymore you can't talk about women's
rights you can't talk about women's
equality you can't talk about the women
uh the alleged women gender pay Gap
um you can't call yourself a woman what
is
the definition of a nonsense word well
that would be a word that has no meaning
and then from there we get the the
standard which I've we've addressed you
know at length but the old uh there's
someone there are some women who can't
get pregnant you see Checkmate checkmate
a woman is a female a female that is the
sex that is supposed to be able to to
Bear Offspring there can be disease
there could be genetic abnormalities
there could be mutations there can be
injury there can be sickness there can
be old age which would all preclude
those things but that is still a
capability that this category of person
is supposed to be able to have let's
continue this question is in the gotcha
that they think it is it's like asking
oh can you define Europe and then having
an eject reaction being that high you
can't Define Europe dulcino Geminis in
Europe of course Germany is in Europe
but what about Greenland what about
Russia what about turkey what's
difficult is about defining the
boundaries not the ones that I'll write
in the middle and turns out turfs can't
properly Define the boundaries either uh
so this is actually not an attempt to
answer the question there's uh and most
of most of the attempts to answer the
question are attempts obviously to evade
the question which is exactly what this
is and by drawing a um a totally
incoherent comparison
not everything is the same not
everything is comparable uh tomato
tomato what's the difference woman is a
biological category a continent is not
even even a country is not we could we
could reduce it down it's talking about
a country um he's not biological
categories and so they aren't comparable
you actually can Define Europe I mean it
has it does have definable boundaries
but even if you can't or even if as well
as you know changes over time and also
okay that actually is a human construct
you see that's the difference well
that's your opinion and it's her opinion
but it's not my opinion it's something
that people come up with and then we
draw the boundaries and we Define it
woman is not a human construct we did
not invent the reality of females we
came up with names for these things but
we didn't come up with the concept
that's the difference I don't know how
else to explain it hopefully that was
clear enough nothing is clear to these
people in the not too distant past
private citizens used to be largely that
if you can imagine private what's
changed while the internet changed think
about everything you've ever searched
for watched or tweeted on the internet
now imagine all of that data being
crawled through collected and aggregated
by Third parties into permanent public
records to keep my data private when I
go online I use expressvpn there are
hundreds of data Brokers out there whose
sole business involves buying and
selling your data they don't even have
to tell you who they're selling it to or
get your consent either one of these
data points is your IP address data
Harvesters use your IP to uniquely
identify you and your physical location
but you can mask your IP address with
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes my
connection to an encrypted server that
makes it more difficult for third
parties to find me if it sounds
complicated it's not because all you
have to do is just tap one button on the
app and then you're protected so if like
me you believe that your data is your
business secure yourself with the number
one rated VPN on the market use MyLink
expressvpn.com Walsh YT to get three
extra months free that's exp
resvpn.com Walsh YT what you'll
frequently see from transphobic people
on platforms such as Twitter or even in
meetings of politicians is that they
start yelling Define women and this has
become a kind of Mantra for the
transphobic movement the concept that
for some reason trans-inclusive people
can't define women but it's rooted in a
fundamental misunderstanding of how
language works and how we Define people
and you see this pretty clearly when you
see people like Graham linam
fail to define a chair in a way that he
ends up including a horse in the
description of the chair or today when
someone responds to a transfer to my
name they Define women and they
responded with someone who Bears or has
the capability to Bear eggs and someone
simply responded to them with a photo of
a man hauling a tray of eggs turn this
off I really that's what we're doing now
well you can't say that women have the
capability to Bear eggs because what
about men who can hold chicken eggs
really you think that is a gotcha you
think really the word literally means to
produce and so the the member of the
human species who can produce eggs that
would be the female well you know a man
can can buy eggs at the grocery store so
that means
this thing about the chair you know you
hear us a lot from the uh the trans
activists first of all again a chair is
actually a human kind it's literally a
human construct it is something that
humans construct it's something that we
make and so it does not belong in the
same category of existence as as
biological entities
um okay we'll do one more I don't even
know why we're doing this nobody can you
know Define what a woman is
you define it
oh I'm good at this uh let me let me
help
women are strength women are power
women are thoughtfulness kindness
understanding never mind no you're not
you're not good at this you're not good
there it is that's the definition women
are strength and power I am all powerful
there it is debunked all right so I
guess we've established what we need to
get to begin with that they can't Define
the term but it was a fun journey to get
back to the same conclusion anyway and
uh we'll wrap it up there talk to you
tomorrow godspeed what is
she made of
[Music]